welcome cleveland's own machine gun
kelly
cleveland
get out your seats everybody get out
your seats right now we're bringing the
energy this year where's the camera at i
want to welcome the world to our city at
cleveland ohio for the 2022 nba all-star
game make some noise out there
[Applause]
i want to enjoy this moment we only get
one of these in our town like every 20
or 25 years so that means next time i
might have some gray hair which is kind
of depressing
um i'm supposed to actually list off
a group of people celebrities who made
it from cleveland but i'm not going to
do that i want to shout out all the hard
workers of this town who keep the heart
pumping i want to shout out all the fans
who fill up the stands whether we're
winning or losing who fill up the arenas
and support the artists they love
make some noise for yourself cleveland
we got the 75th anniversary team in the
house tonight
and of course the reason why we're all
here we have the best basketball players
in the world here to play on our court
for the nba all-star game make some
noise for them
all right look
i'm not a great basketball
okay i'm not even a good basketball
player but i did steal all the infinity
stones from thanos so lebron if if you
need me i could probably sing something
from half court while i'm wearing this
tonight just let me know i'll be happy
to step out
um djd nice let's get the party started
one more time cleveland make some noise
that's right cleveland make some noise
cleveland it's nba all-star 2022 and i
go by the name of d-nice and i'm so
hyped to be here we have two i mean two
incredible teams getting ready to go
heads up it's time to get this party
started are you ready to rock with me
right now
i said are you ready to rock with me
right now cleveland
well it's only right that i give it some
ohio flavor for these ohio players
cleveland are you ready
all right to get things started i got a
legend from the lone star state to help
me out dirk tell them what's up
if speed and strength is your thing then
this is your team these guys can create
off the dribble they can score
in the post and trust me they can fly
this is team durant
the head coach for team durant is making
his second all-star appearance just
named one of the top 15 nba coaches of
all time
from the miami heat eric exposed
injured and unable to attend is the
captain of team durant 12-time all-star
kevin durant
[Applause]
and now for your team durant reserves
unable to compete due to injury he's a
four-time all-star a three-time nba
champion from the golden state warriors
draymond
green
making his all-star game debut
in the league's rainy rookie of the year
from the charlotte hornets
also making his first appearance is one
of the most versatile players in the
game representing the san antonio first
dejante
murray
[Applause]
he's a two-time slam dunk champion and a
two-time all-star from the chicago bulls
zach
[Music]
a three-time all-star and a three-time
kid defensive player rookie of the year
from the utah jazz rudy gobert
making his third all-star appearance
from the 2021 nba champion milwaukee
bucks chris middleton
[Applause]
another three-time all-star from the
western conference leading phoenix suns
[Music]
[Applause]
david named rookie of the year in 2016
and a three-time all-star from the
minnesota timberwolves carl anthony
towns
[Applause]
and now
the starters for team durant
that's how i get back in the street
[Music]
a three-time all-star from the boston
celtics now making his second
consecutive start
jason
tatum he was the number one pick in the
2014 nba draft and the rookie of the
year in 2015
making his all-star game debut
from the golden state warriors andrew
wiggins
he's ranked in top five in both scoring
and assist this season a two-time
all-star from the atlanta hawks making
his second start
[Applause]
the 2020 kia nba rookie of the year
and one of the league's most elected
flying players
appearing in this first all-star game
from the memphis grizzlies
[Music]
he dominates the paint and he leads the
entire league in scoring
named of starter for the fifth
consecutive year from the philadelphia
76ers
[Applause]
[Music]
let's hear it one more time for team
duran
team durant will give their best tonight
to benefit the greater cleveland food
bank
[Music]
i